all right Hutch how are you doing Mark
great welcome back thank you thank you
for having me again it's a pleasure yeah
you're always you're always one of my
favorite people to talk to that you said
that the other day in an interview and
it
um it reminded me that I need to put you
in my top five blessings that I I count
every day when you said that it made me
cry bro it made me cry you saying that I
am somebody that can that comes to your
mind right when you think of something
good imagine just that Pro that
thought what kind of compliment is that
when I think of this person it helps me
throughout my
day
what
um that's the most beautiful thing
somebody's ever said about me ever yeah
I'm so proud that you are part of this
project I am so proud to be a part of it
I've I've gotten um I've gotten so much
out of it that I can't I can't
remember what it was like before it
almost does that make sense I um I like
uh it's become such a big part of my
life a lot of people have when I say a
lot I
mean hundreds of people have said thank
you you know and to have somebody thank
you just for selling your [__] soul
on a camera is is
um it's a beautiful thing that I can
appreciate today you know as somebody
that who's come
from nothing man and been able to make a
life for myself now and with people's
help the people on this channel are
unwaveringly empathetic the viewers yeah
yeah the people that um like I I pulled
up in a in a in a legal car that was
born in the teens and I got it from the
the people that donated money to a g
[__] fundme that that that was
started that saved me and my son in a
time where I couldn't save
us people reached into their like I
can't okay it's so hard to understand
how like I'd be I'd be looking at it and
my bank account would just it would get
hit with money and it would say that
somebody donated 500 [__] dollar500
[__] dollar I've never donated that I
I just can't but like to think and like
half of them were like veterans that
were like hey man I hey I hope this
helps you hope it like it [__] helped
it [__] helped I'm letting you guys
know right now it did more than help it
saved me when I couldn't save myself it
didn't go to drugs it went to what you
see today it went to the best like I
used it in the way that that they wanted
me too I got a car I got a place to live
um I got my son in school like
um nobody had to do that nobody had to
do that how do you say thank you for
that I don't know I don't know I [__]
love you guys whoever did that and the
people that didn't like I
I I'm moved actually moved inside of
myself from that my spirit is growing
based off of the love and empathy people
have poured out toward me and my family
um people that don't know me that that
who have listened to me speak and say
that it moved them is I never thought
that I would be somebody that somebody
wanted to listen to I never did my whole
life I've been told to shut the [__] up
when you talk when you're loud right and
I'm a loud guy um you're told to shut
the [__] up more than you're told what
would you say say people shut the [__]
up from the moment I could talk I was
told to shut up I I I believe that I
remember that that's how I remember my
child at least just because I was an
emotional kid and I had a lot to say but
in those times you know kids were meant
to be seen not
heard you know um but the amount
of like if you if you okay so there's in
in life right
we have times where we
doubt what God may be or what
spirituality might be or or love we
doubt
love I can raise my right hand and
testament that it is real it is real
it's there and it's for us and people
have showed it to me people have given
it to me love actual love and I'm not
saying saying in like a relationship way
I'm saying it in just a way of um
how dare I not live the best version of
myself while people are giving like
literally were donating out of their own
[__] they work hard these people work
hard I believe you guys work
hard and then they reached in their
pocket and L just handed it to me I
didn't have to do anything but wake up
in the [__] morning I don't know how
to thank you I don't know how to say
thank you for that I can't describe the
feeling inside of me I wish I had better
words words to
describe it just brought tears to my
eyes a lot but that's not the most
important thing at all you know that was
just something
[Music]
that that showed me that it's okay to
live okay it's okay to live okay it's
okay to be okay with myself a big part
of that though is you being able to
accept it because a lot of people if
they got donations like you
got would have would have screwed it up
they wouldn't feel feel like they
deserved it they would have spent it the
wrong ways right and they would have
self-destructed further right and the
guil the guilt from and the shame from
[__] it up would have even driven him
further exactly I chose I I could have I
was there I was there I was on the
precipice of Sinker swim and then a
bunch of people handed me money and said
here we're going to trust you with this
and and hope you do the right thing with
it and I did I did the right thing with
it I um I made sure that myself and my
family were going to be okay I ended up
going into treatment you know I I I that
that that's just just a side note that's
why I don't want to do a GoFundMe for
everybody I interview because I believe
about 95% of them would have could kill
themselves with it yeah they could kill
themselves they could they could screw
it up everyone would would regret
donating it would just be bad right I
don't I
mean I can't ask anybody for anything
I've gotten everything I need I've
gotten everything I need I wake up in
the morning with literally wish I had
something I wish I had something I mean
I have a lot of
memories and I have a lot of fun stories
we're going to talk about a lot of fun
stories I want to paint a picture for
people and I'd love to call it
depictions we'll call it depictions of
my my perception of different human
beings that I served with and the way
that they conducted themselves and the
way that they conduct themselves now
because believe it or
not my best friend is a guy we call that
we nicknamed in the unit I give him the
nickname kangi the cat his name is Brian
kangi okay now anybody that knows this
guy knows why we call him the cat
because he's got nine [__] lives okay
this is the dude who's an immigrant from
the Philippines right and he joins the
military so that he can get a
citizenship his father had moved out
here for business he moved with his dad
as a teenager not knowing [__] getting
scuffed up beat up you know the whole
nine trying to learn English as a little
Filipino kid this man is made of solid
[__]
iron unkillable he's he's unkillable um
Brian kangi goes to Afghanistan in 2001
like right after the war starts like
literally 911 his kids in Afghanistan 6
months later as an immigrant right he
went to Texas to learn English the
military set him up sends him to
Afghanistan goes to
Afghanistan he goes to a place called
Shin which is like no [__] joke these
guys have constantina wire is their base
see what constantina wire is a razor
wire right the razor wire you see not
barb wire but like the [__] razor
blade one that was the base that's what
it that's what protected them three rows
and one stacked on top no armor and
they're just [__] driving up and down
with a with an artillery piece attached
to their [__] humy in the mountains
in
01 I can't imagine how scary that was I
imagine it was [__] scary so the dude
comes back they have a great tour they a
good tour he comes back he wants to
probably
go let's not put him on blast too hard
so he probably wants to go enjoy his
Friday night and it might have to do
with naked women I'm not sure maybe just
to see them you know go to one of these
nice facilities they have that they've
set up that were women get naked and
then men throw money at them I you know
to each his own and um
Brian King is sitting in an ATM and he
pulls 60 bucks out and a guy sticks a
gun through the sunroof of his car and
says give me that 60 bucks and he said
what 60 bucks and the guy shoots him two
times in his chest pop pop and walks
away now there's an immigrant fighting
for our country back home sitting in an
ATM on a Friday night at 8:00 and gets
shot twice in his [__] chest and he
says all he could
remember Brian I love you sorry dude all
he could remember was
thinking he's dying and he his he
couldn't he was he was passing out
because he couldn't breathe he was shot
in his lung and he couldn't breathe and
he just remembers that people were
running up to the
car but they were the same race as the
person that shot him and he said the
last thing he remembers is locking his
[__]
doors what does that tell
you because he didn't know who's who but
because a dude that shot him was a
certain race and body that came up to
his car was the same race he's like [__]
this and locked the goddamn doors these
people are trying to pull him out and
help him patch him up he's like [__]
this lock the door so that's just how I
met him this had already happened when I
got there right so he's already healed
up they flew his family in from the
[__] Philippines like your kid's
dying he's having these gnarly
hallucinations on morphine he's going
you know and I meet him and he's a
Corporal and this guy has like he has he
smokes marar Reds still to this day and
it looks like he smokes like he can't
get cancer I don't know if that makes
any sense but the way he [__] smoke
cigarettes is like cancer is not an
option here because you can just watch
the [__] he's pulling on a cigarette
and you can just watch the thing [__]
going down an ash falling you know he's
one of those smokers like you would
think of like somebody in Egypt you know
you see smokers in Egypt the cab drivers
are just like and the [__] whole
thing goes so that's clangy the cat so I
get there and I'm like this guy's
[__] I could tell right away cuz I'm
from the city this guy's [__] with it
this guy's with the business I'm going
to watch him I want to be like this guy
he just made
Corporal which is an NCO position but
it's a lateral promotion which means
you're still at E4 so specialist is a
rank in the Army let me give you the
ranks okay from zero to E9 you have
private private second class private
first class that's E1 E2 E3 these are
your pay grades as well as your rank
okay E4 has two ranks you have
specialist which means you specialize in
your job now you you know they promote
you to say that you're a subject matter
expert in what you're supposed to be
doing and then you have Corporal
Corporal is a two stripes okay two
Chevrons and that is a leader so now
you're a leader but you don't get paid
anymore it's a lateral promotion you're
kind it's it's the worst [__] NCO
position to have in the Army because you
still get treated like [__] but you have
to yell at your friends you know so is a
Corporal so anybody that's a Corporal
you respect because they are in they're
in like the worst [__] position you
could be in and um then you make E5
which is three chevrons now you're a
buck Sergeant a sergeant then there's E6
staff sergeant E7 which is Sergeant
First Class to remove a [__] Sergeant
First class's rank it takes an act of
Congress as far as I heard then you have
E8 which is Master Sergeant or if you're
in command is an E8 you're a first
sergeant which has a diamond in between
three Chevron up and three chevrons down
above that is E9 sergeant major Andor
command sergeant major the difference
between sergeant major and command
sergeant major is a sergeant major isn't
in charge of men but you know he has
probably like some sort of
um uh like a uh position in an office
somewhere okay or he's working behind
the scenes but a sergeant major a
command sergeant major has the three
chevrons up three chevrons down with an
eagle in it right that's how you know
he's in charge of men usually a
battalion a battalion size which is
three um batteries in artillery we have
we call them batteries not companies we
call them sections not squads we have a
chief not a squad leader um our platoon
sergeants are called gunny our gunnery
sergeant and a smokem man they call him
smok man oh okay so I want to stay on
kangy for a second because our [__]
kids are best friends he has a
10-year-old son I have a 10-year-old son
when I got my [__] together this time he
wanted to be around me again now this is
the biggest blessing a man can have to
have somebody not only he [__] loves
cares about cherishes and respects but
that person wants to be in my life too
he wants to he he loves cherishes and
respects me somebody that never thought
they were respectable and um but our
kids are best friends it's chance and
Brent you know and uh so kangi right we
go to Afghanistan the second time he for
his second time my first
time the worst [__] that could happen
happens to him you know I don't think he
lost life in Afghanistan the second time
I he'll probably correct me if I'm wrong
but I know that let's let's move on to
Iraq so when we deploy to Iraq he's
already a buck
Sergeant I make Buck Sergeant right and
I made I made E5 in the fastest amount
amount of time possible I made it in
just under three years ju we're about at
three
years and um Kang and I are good friends
at this time we we leave for Iraq on
something called advon which is like
Advanced party so in order to set up a
unit before they get to where they're
deploying to they have to send like a
team to make sure they find everybody
where everybody's going to live you lay
out you know you know what I mean you
get a feeling um you you get a feel for
the unit everything like that and I was
in a very unique position in my my unit
to where I was able to be
used basically you could plug me in to
any position we had in the unit I
qualified in all the artillery pieces I
did everything the boys did and I worked
in the background as well with the
command team so when they sent us Brian
of course they stick him in a [__]
truck with these guys that we're about
to replace he goes on Convoy and boom
hey the first guy our unit's not even
[__] there yet first guy in our unit
to go outside the wire gets blown up so
Kang's [__] I can imagine him this is
how I imagine what happened because the
way they described it sounds and went
like this this other unit that were
taking over for is telling us they go
your FR got [__] blown up and he gets
out of the truck and he just takes his
helmet off and he throws it at he goes
[__] [__] why me why me
always me man that's how he handled it
dusted the goddamn Flame off his
shoulders put his helmet back on got in
the truck and boogie that's Brian kangy
kangy the cat then he got hit like four
more times he got like two or three more
I don't know how many times he got DET
he got attached to like some some grunt
unit and he was doing like some special
[__] with some [__] with them guys and
he gets the dude [__] has died like
we get back from Iraq eventually you
know half of
ourselves you know we don't come back
complete but we came back
and um Brian goes man I need two more
[__] lives and I said why Brian he
goes one for my wife and one for my kid
man cuz he knew he was going to have one
so he met this beautiful girl in back in
the Philippines when he was
visiting and she wants to be a nurse and
guess what today she's a [__] nurse
and she lives out here and they had a
kid and our kids are best [__]
friends so that's clangy the cat the
most the man I respect the most out of
my unit
never heard him
complain you know [__]
[__] y me that's probably the
the loud that's the only time I've ever
heard Brian complain now when
oh never complain when we're coming back
from Afghanistan my second tour they
[__] ins stops him they stop him and
hold him in Germany talking about your
citizenships up this [__] dude is on
deployment and it's like all right we're
going home we're done and they hold him
and this other guy dirty sanchez we call
him dirty sanchez he was um a dude from
Colombia and he was in the Colombian
Army and he was just [__] he's just a
Colombian beautiful man but he was not I
mean he was looked like a rodent but he
was mean and he was [__] tough and
funny and they hold both of these guys
ins holds these guys so we say we're not
going [__] nowhere we'll miss flights
I don't give a [__] the whole unit got
to together and we talked about it we
were going to petition like it was like
time to write a petition we're not
[__] leaving without our
guys so it worked out we we all left
together I I don't know what happened
but Brian didn't get deported neither
did Dirty Sanchez
um but that actually happened to where
immigration held up two soldiers in
another country saying they may not
[__] return to the United States
after 13 months in combat for
it please can anyone out there explain
to me where the [__] they got the notion
that that would be okay that it'd be
okay to stop these two [__] men who
just put their lives on the line for a
year straight for the a nation that's
not theirs a nation they don't [__]
come from a nation they weren't born
in and we hold them up in Germany and
say hey you guys can't come
back [__] around and find out that's the
way we do
business thanks but hang on here we got
to make sure your paperwork's straight
okay okay shot twice in ATM did a tour
before but let's wait make sure his
paperwork straight for sure good
job that was uh
2005 okay so that's how well ins was
working then I wonder how it's working
now
so long story
short well long story long is I'm able
to call I could call him right now and
he'll pick up the [__] phone and he'd
come he'd come here right now if I said
I was in trouble Brian kangy kangy the
cat a man I respect more than anybody in
the
world I love him and I'm grateful for
him every day in my top five people I
pray for when I wake up you Mark and him
are in that so is my brother
Kenny
um but I count my blessings today
dude I count I'm counting my [__]
blessings I I
really he didn't complain the [__] do I
have to complain about right now I'm
healthy I'm happy I'm clean and sober I
am I got I have everything I need I
really don't have much to complain about
you know and a lot of that has to do
with the people here a lot of that has
to do
with me having to figure out that it's
okay to be
okay you know a lot of us have problems
especially addicts
we have problems figuring
out the fact that our life is worth
living life period is a beautiful
[__] thing and it's worth living but
existence is
expensive you know existence is
expensive don't let anybody lie to you
you can't just I mean I wish we could
just live for free
but it's expensive more than just a
monetary way it's it's more expensive in
a way of we have to SA
sacrifice and shed these [__] fears
and these things we've convinced
ourselves are true we've sat here and
told ourselves all this terrible [__]
about oursel over and over and
self-loathing and saying like I'm not
[__] worth it I'm not good enough I'm
not I'm
not it's time to change the language man
you have to wake up one day and say I am
I am I am I am I'm beautiful I'm okay
I'm nice I'm kind I love people my like
the way that I have been able to change
in a in a meaningful
way is that I look at my life now as a
as a person that
navigates consciously trying to end
every interaction I have with another
human being with hopefully they have the
feeling that they want to have that and
interaction with me again is it easy no
no because not everybody's the same and
and some people don't want to have a
[__] interaction with you but at the
very least even if they don't they won't
say [__] [__] prick you know why
don't we get into some characters can I
lay out some characters for you mark
please okay we'll call it depictions of
the war and the men that I know in it
that we're in it I can start with oh let
me start with the one of the two
greatest leaders I ever served under
okay one his name is Captain John wellan
and I hope he sees this video John wahan
was a E6 in the Moog he was a medic in
the Moog Mogadishu right half of his
[__] files blacked out this dude's a
bad [__] re he just and then he
joins the Army and becomes an officer
right so if you're in the military and
you know most officers initially not
really respected not really respect a
bull they're still figuring [__] out
right they need a they need a enlisted
guy to kind of Coach them along on how
to act well this dude came from the
unlisted ranks as a veteran as a
ranger then joins and becomes an
artillery
Commander when we were in
Afghanistan my buddy
David my David Gray a guy my dad married
he like was the you know held this you
know my dad was like the ordained
minister for him and his wife Sarah
and um they have three beautiful
children now and he's like a sergeant
major he's still in the Army he's still
in the
82nd um he's moved around but he still
is Dave
so
um Dave they had a mission for this MP
unit the night before it was
Midsummer I remember and they're
shooting a loom rounds which in in a
loom round is you have a we're shooting
155 millim cannons so in a loom round is
is this [__] tall and it's just a
canister basically it's empty and it has
a flare in there so they fire it and and
as it reaches its Pinnacle the flare
releases and then the canister this is
all calculated the canister
Falls and it's already calculated like
they do the math to make sure that
canister doesn't fall on anything right
so they shoot a [__] mission like
nine alom rounds for this MP unit right
and MPS are milit police right these are
guys that join the Army to bust other
people in the Army right got to respect
these guys you know they join the Army
to become cops and
arrest other soldiers that was their
idea when they joined God I love him but
um they were doing something some Patrol
and we shoot Al rounds for him Dave
shoots like [__] six or seven or
eight I can't remember he shoots a
handful over five Alum rounds for these
guys so the next day some
major comes from the command here at s
fob Sero which is like 900 [__]
people it's not the kind of Base you you
want to [__] around you know it's a lot
of rough necks you know it's grunt it's
all combat people
um and this major comes down and he
walks right onto our gun line right a
gun line is um we had six howitzers and
the gun line is off limits to anybody
that's not in the unit that's like a
known thing it's like walking on a
flight line you know you don't walk up
to it and pass and start taking pictures
you know you might get [__] up so this
major crosses the road walks right up to
the he knew which set it which which
which um he knew exactly which um
section fired the Alum rounds walks
right onto the gun line finds Dave and
his guys and starts calling them baby
killers this major did because he said a
man walked up with his dead daughter
which did happen and said that our alom
canister came through his house blew it
up and killed his daughter
so
90.9% of that story is most likely false
what happened was is this dude was
probably making a goddamn IED and it
popped in his [__] house and it
killed his kid but he said I know I can
get a paycheck because you bring a dead
child to an American Bas and say you
guys did this we pay you cash don't let
anybody lie I don't give a [__] what
anybody says that's exact exactly how it
goes
100% we pay cash for your [__]
dead being a rich country man
so so now Dave's locked up and he's got
all these guys at parade rest and he's
screaming in their [__] faces you
[__] killed a kid you dumb shits what
the [__] is wrong with you you dumb
[__] we have to deal with this
now and Captain well
isn't the type of dude you [__] walk
up to his men and yell at so he walks
right up and says Serge if you don't
remove yourself from this gun line I'll
[__] remove you myself you don't talk
to my men again this is my gunline I can
legally throw you off of it get the [__]
off my gun line the commander of that
gun line is in charge and he can throw a
general off technically but it's his gun
line if he says it's not safe for you to
be there you got to get the [__] out he
said sir I'm telling you if you don't
turn yourself the [__] around and get
off of my gunline in front of his Manny
saying it right I will remove you he's
basically saying I'll knock you the [__]
out bro right and Captain willan from
Tennessee he's a country boy that night
we heard about it everybody hears oh my
God Captain just told this major to go
[__] himself right and Dave's like bro
this guy just came down and said we
killed a kid so Dave and his sections
all [__] up right they're thinking
they did this terrible [__]
this dumbass major just jumped the gun
basically he thought he was special I
wish I knew his name so I could [__]
call him out in public but um he was in
our
Battalion and uh captain willan that
night I remember it was Pitch Black
there was no moon it was a pretty night
it was a nice night but it was Pitch
Black we couldn't hear [__] and they
call everybody at like 8:30 at night in
a formation and that's different that
doesn't happen after dinner you know so
you get his we get the whole unit lined
up everybody he waits for every single
person to get there must must have taken
an hour he gets his whole unit lined up
and he he gots this he has this
information and he lights up a [__]
cigar and he's in his T-shirt no joke
with his Tennessee hat and he lights up
a [__] cigar and he's walking up and
down all you can see is the gloat to his
cigar as he's walking up and down and
hitting it and he goes men I need you
men to know something
now he says when you make a mistake it's
my
fault when you do something right it's
yours and he said I will not be your
commander for much longer they're
removing me from my command but I want
you men to know that I love you and that
I'm proud of you and that you served
honorably in front of
me and you're great
Men You're great
men I was 21 years old and I never been
talked to like
that and I believed him because he was a
great man he is a great man he said when
you do something wrong it's my fault
when you do something right it's
yours he he took responsibility for
everything that happened he told Dave
and his guys you guys don't you dare for
one minute think you made a mistake you
did everything I've asked you to and
thank you for that thank you you I asked
you to shoot those rounds you shot them
exactly how I asked you to none of you
made a mistake yesterday none of you
killed anybody I did I
did ends up we had this [__] genius
named Lieutenant Tomlinson that did the
math and he said in order for our Loom
canister to have hit that house the
winds would have had to be over 300
miles an
hour
right they removed him from command
and we lost Captain willan big one of
the biggest loss in my military career
and they promoted
him he became the commander of um like
jump Master school or something he he be
he he got promoted because he's a bad
[__] you can't you know you
really don't can't hurt harm somebody
like that with un you know he was just a
bad man like a badass badass he's not a
bad man he's a great man I [__] love
him we're friends on Facebook friends on
Facebook um that was the best commander
I ever under under other than Captain
Felix Rodriguez who is more like a
gazelle this dude could run like I I I
when I think of him I still see like
prancing as he runs because he just this
guy goes like a [__] bird man he
could [__] fly um really respectable
Commander he was my commander in Iraq
and we became friends because I worked
directly under him for a moment doing
some things that he needed and um he was
a great Commander as well I'm not going
to say say y wasn't but we just weren't
on the same page um but okay so then the
F best the craziest and best let's go to
the ncos right the non-commission
officers I had a first sergeant named
first sergeant Jeffrey Robinson now this
man now you imagine somebody he's been
to Ranger school he's done all this
highspeed
[__] but I don't know how like if you
you could see a [__] hard dick
walking down the street that's this dude
he could he was he looked like he was
made of leather and he looked like he
was somebody that just [__] worked
out all day every day he was made of
stone and his face was made of leather
handsome but in a really like he been
punched in the [__] face and punched
to the people he just looked hard
[__] core and he talked like this
brother hey and he talked just like that
that's how he talk and I remember the
the funniest thing I've ever heard a man
say to another man what came out of
first sergeant Robinson's mouth top
Robinson but this man also was a loving
a great father a great husband uh like
somebody to really look up to as it came
to who he was as a person was admirable
and commendable but this
dude literally used to tell this guy
Nethers I [__] harder than you run you
can go home and ask my
wife now when you're running in
formation down a road in the morning and
there's other people running by you and
your first Sergeant has somebody who's
falling behind and he's yelling so loud
that people at the [__] PX up the
block can hear it you goddamn oh you
piece of [__] I [__] harder than you run
how do you even [__] live with
yourself you you know what call my wife
you call her now you P [__] and he's
doing it with a dip of Copenhagen in his
mouth
running you [__] [__] with a dip of
Copenhagen in his mouth running miles
like a like it's nothing like it's not
there this man was made of pure [__]
iron sharpened into blued steel right
this is the man that if he said come on
let's go everybody's like for sure you
know that's a guy that I want to be
around when shit's popping off because
he top Robinson was the guy that like in
Iraq like when shit's going off like and
and sometimes you'd be driving and it
would just start looking like Star Wars
the tracers are just going everywhere
every
direction he's the guy that gets out of
the truck and it's talking to people
while bullets are [__] flying that's
this guy he doesn't [__] blink he
doesn't wink nothing shakes him he [__]
harder than some people
run that's a [__] achievement in
itself man that's an accomplishment I
want to hand to this
man we argued over him having a a pink
shirt one time and he called it salmon
and I what the [__] is salmon bro you're
wearing a pink shirt don't [__] Hut
it's salmon bro I said oh yeah yes sir
Roger that Roger that top you got it
but when my
dad came to visit when we got back from
Iraq it was during All-American week and
in the 82nd Airborne Division
All-American a week everybody has to
participate but he knew I was getting
out of the army and he knew my dad um
was older and and he really respected
that my father was a Vietnam vet and he
let me take he didn't make me go he
didn't make me go to all- American week
I'm sorry for my bad for D you're out
top
but and he was so sweet to my father i'
never seen him talk like that to another
person I only seen him as his hardcore
[__] like you know I I want to [__]
as hard as him and he just softened up
in the way he spoke to my dad and just
don't worry about it guys yeah you guys
go have fun and enjoy yourselves and
Hutch don't worry about it I love you
brother these men will live with me for
the rest of my life in the most
beautiful way thank God thank God for
them thank God that they
exist you know because that's what I
believe our country is made out of
people like this you know where we come
from all he was from North Carolina we
come from all these different places and
we come from all these different
backgrounds and all these different
things and in the
end if you're watching at the right time
you just see Love come out of them you
know even the hardest ones it's in there
they're just sweet people
um okay let's give you some contrast on
for AR Robinson is his sweet
ass in
Afghanistan okay we had another
character named Mike I'll just say his
last name his name is Burk halter okay
now everybody in my unit that watches
this is GNA laugh their ass off just by
saying the name Burk halter so
Burkhalter when I got there had been in
the Army for four years and was still a
PFC okay and if you've ever met a real
Forest
Gump I'm not saying this offensively
Michael Burkhalter was a [__]
Force Gump dude
because he he's a boy from Texas but he
didn't speak
English but he didn't speak Spanish
either that's the deal that's exactly
how we got down so when you're having a
conversation with him you need to make
sure that you statements only Burk
halter you need to go to the
bathroom and he's on right but this dude
could run a 20K with a pack of maros in
his [__] mouth and
win he was just born able to run and
smoke non-filtered
cigarettes God made this man to run he
could [__] run and in the 82nd that's
something you got to do a lot so Burke
alter would get in trouble a lot but not
really because he'd put up these
physical numbers right he could run like
a [__] gazelle just like fix
cat Rod but so Burk halter makes the
mistake a mistake that not many of us
knew the consequences are but first joh
Robinson made sure to make these
consequences quite clear so Burkhalter
what he did was he was on Tower guard
and in the
Army there's only one of two ways you
can still be [__] executed by your
own command team right and one of them
Burke halter happened to pull off if you
fall asleep he didn't pull it off
completely but we got the picture from
first Robinson I I'll paint it right now
if you fall asleep on Tower guard and
somebody sneaks by and kills another
Soldier your punishment is
death today at least in 2005 according
to the univ uni uniform code of military
Justice the UCMJ you could be executed
for that so first sergeant Robinson no
[__]
joke lines us all up and blindfolds this
[__] dude and
puts puts him up against the
wall and explains to
us that if you fall asleep on Tower gard
and somebody dies you can be [__]
executed and he goes
Ready
Aim this dude [__] his
[__] with a blindfold on a tide be
his
back just to prove a point he wanted to
prove the
point that if you [__] get somebody
hurt on my watch I'll [__] kill you
right here when we got there okay so
when we get to
Afghanistan um in April it was April
14th we got to Afghanistan 2005
okay the unit that was there before us
that we were taking over for was from
Hawaii I think they were I cannot
remember who they were uh 25th maybe I
can't remember who they were from but
they had somebody an E5 that had passed
away while on duty on tour but it wasn't
the way that you would think he decided
he was going to correct a weap a weapon
malfunction in front of the
weapon so this guy is it's a saw it's
squad automatic weapon it gets a jam
it's on a turret he stands in front of
it Barrel into his [__] chest opens
the feed tray removes the jam puts
another round in slams the [__] feed
tray not knowing that there's a round in
the bolt that's already retracted slams
The feed tray bolt flies forward feeds
the round fires it and kills
him and they have this huge like
memorial thing
right well top Robinson ain't playing no
dumb [__] so as soon as the unit
leaves he goes over there and [__]
tears the [__] out of this [__] thing
get this [__] [__] out of my sight
and we're like yo what's up dude and he
goes I'm not going to [__] glorify a
[__] thank God for this
man we need more like him in in the
world he said this is a poster for how
to kill yourself being
stupid that's for sergeant
Robinson that's first sergeant
Robinson we got the Burke
halter
Kang we can
talk so I'm in Iraq right and I'm on a
mission with my buddy Rick and James
and a set that I used to love deploying
with right and um that I used to go on
Mission with a lot um and we encounter
we find an IED and it's literally 50
[__] feet from we stop we see it my
buddy Rick sees it Convoy pull two
trucks up and there's an Iraqi police
station across the street from it so we
have a kurdistani [__] interpreter
now if you've ever met a kurdistani
person these [__] people are like the
Israelis you cannot you cannot kill them
there they will fight to the last man
woman and child the Kurds are who
[__] fought off Isis they the Kurds
are based in Iraq and fought all the way
into Syria men women and women these are
the bravest [__] people in the world
but the Kurds didn't play uh they don't
they don't play but they spoke
Arabic so our interpreter is like no
[__] that these guys know exactly who
put that there so we're going to make
them remove it EOD is now Iraqi police
today now these Iraqi policemen knew
exactly what the [__] was across the
street they knew that [__] was an ed
right but my buddy Rick is telling The
Interpreter no no no tell him to pick it
up first the interpreting makes a guy
get butt naked and starts hitting him
with a sh with something right because
he's like you know because he knew what
was going on and he was really pissed
off at this dude for knowing what was
going on so he's hitting this guy and
the guy's butt naked we're like no no no
we don't know if you have a weapon take
your pants off the whole thing right so
then we're like hey you need to remove
that IED you know who [__] put it
there and my buddy Rick is filming this
and he's like no no and the guy gets up
and he gets up and
kicks it right no no no no no no pick it
up pick it up and throw it so this guy
is literally urinating on himself naked
and he has to pick up this [__] live
IED and walk it as far as he can and
then The Interpreter said okay stop wait
hold it let's get in the trucks and
go that happened in real life I watched
that happen this man get butt ass naked
have to pick up an explosive device that
he knows was meant for us and hold it
100t off the road as we drove by we're
putting the spotlights on them as we're
driving the nines right because [__] him
[__] them anyways dude the [__] they're
wearing Glocks where do you think they
got those where' they get the Glocks you
know I can tell
you the old us of bay same place that
uh we donated so many Munitions
to Afghanistan for the Taliban so
beautiful it's amazing how good we're at
we are at at um walking away from
war we do it by handing weapons to to
bad guys um
so that that's just one example of like
how things can work out if you're when
you're on the road um I have two more
pretty good ones that I like to talk
it's not about you know I don't I don't
know any rambos I just know real people
actual human beings that lived that I
knew actually you know not just looked
them up on Google um
so we're
driving our Convoy this is the same no
it was two different convoys it was one
after the other so the first
Convoy okay I'll tell the funny story
first and then the other one next okay
so we're driving to a place called
Anaconda and Anaconda was a base
believe I cannot remember if it was
outside of toit or Kook but it was north
of Baghdad and this place was so big it
was an Air Force bace it was so big it
was broken up into quadrants okay and if
mortars were hitting one quadrant the
other three weren't even alerted that's
how big this Bas was I seen a C5 land
you can hear that [__] coming from
[__] Mississippi dude I didn't if you
ever heard of C5 land it's unmistakable
it screams for days
but where we're
driving we just get out of a place
called taji and we're pulling North and
we pull around Baghdad and we make it we
don't have to stop in Baghdad this time
we're going straight through so we
sometimes we'd spend the night and buy
up Baghdad International Airport that's
where Saddam had like a solid gold
toilet and like this dude was so nuts
Saddam was so
crazy that in one of his palaces in
Baghdad that I saw he had F he'd walk
out of his front door
as far as I remember maybe this wasn't
his house I don't know could have been
UD or cuda's but he had 52 pathways on a
man-made lake that was small like a golf
course Lake 52 Pathways that walked to
these little houses so he had 52 of them
in 180 degree turn right from when he
walked out of his house and that was for
every Monday I'm guessing when he would
leave his Palace he would walk and there
would be some poor man's daugh daughter
in there who had never been with a man
before kidnapped from their family and
held in this little house until Saddam
wanted to have his way with her that
week 52 weeks in a
year that's the kind of sick [__] we
were talking about you
know when it comes to thinking of that
kind of [__] I don't mind that that we
were there that kind of [__] makes me
okay with us invading that country but
then again I think of you
know all the profits that were
made here's a
story
so a friend of
mine named
montin and everybody in our our [__]
knows who I'm talking about he was
driving in an APC an armored personnel
carrier that it was made for the Arctic
I can't remember what these [__]
things were called it was made for the
Arctic but it worked really well in the
desert because it was airtight right so
the AC worked but he's in one of these
in the he was a truck Commander so he
was in the passenger side and as they
are passing a
streetlight there's an efp remember that
thing I talked about last time inside of
the pole cut out and ready for him to
drive by and as he passed it that [__]
blew and it came straight through his
armored personnel carrier hit him in the
hip and split him like that okay he
lived because of this guy Doc Johnson
who I'll describe later it literally
split him in
half
legitimately like clossing me back for
the rest of his life he's a hero in my
eyes but and then it bounced off his
hipbones so it was burning so hot it
came right through the steel but our
bone is a lot harder to burn I guess cuz
it hit him in the hip split him and
bounced out and went right out the other
side this thing is burning so [__]
hot that the ambient air inside of the
truck was expunged from the heat so
they're all
suffocating right so all the doors you
know his smoking door pops open he falls
out half like literally his left hip is
holding him together you know you could
see his spine on both
sides
right cuz it burned his [__] uniform
half off so he falls out of the
truck and they're they're escorting
refrigerated trucks you
know so it was illegal for us to look
inside any vehicle we were
escorting and I'll tell you
why so you know a couple of us decided
no [__] this I want to know why my
buddies split in half sit laying on the
ground dying I want to know what it's
for bolt cutters crack pop the lock
crack it open pull that frig open and
six of us are sitting there looking in
the back of this truck and what do you
think we
see Taco Bell Burger King and [__]
Pizza
Hut that's what was in the truck in
front of
him and he's sitting there bleeding out
in the [__] road for it now tell me
who signed up for that and then on the
base I'm paying eight bucks a
Whopper a pizza is
$22 a [__] bean burrito with red
sauce and onions is like six
bucks little did they tell us we were
the [__] people dying to bring it
there listen I'd rather go without a
Whopper and have one less Mission I'd
rather go without Taco B and not have
this man split in half I don't know
about you guys do you I mean who do many
people people know that that was going
on AES had a contract with these [__]
companies and we're dying to bring it to
it's Comfort it's Comfort though right
you know the big bases need their
Comforts I wasn't on some [__]
comfortable base you know I mean I was
in the end yeah but I couldn't buy I'm
not going to buy it I'm not going to buy
it because I know what's happening so
that's the kind of profit people don't
realize we being made it's not just
halberton and [__] and Dick
Cheney talk Bell Pizza Pepsi Cola was
making a [__] killing dude a killing
off of arm boys and girls
dying [__] You Pepsi Cola [__] you for
real I drink Coke [__]
so they the medic saved his life by um
laying down a
poncho and wrapping them in it put them
back
together squeeze them together like he's
made of clay and wrapped him in a Ponch
and tied it on both sides saved his life
a guy named Doc Johnson a white kid he
um never made it past pv2 his whole
career because the [__] that boy saw and
had to deal with made him a [__]
crazy person and if you went to the defa
with Don Doc Johnson if you're going to
the defa to eat dinner don't sit within
five feet of him because he's swinging
at somebody he just loved it when
somebody would ask him a question he
just [__] hit him in the mouth pow
doc why you fighting every [__] him I
that's how he dealt with it he was a 20
something year old
kid pulling a guy that's in a
V pulling him together and wrapping him
in a poncho and tying it to save his
life I who how do you even [__] think
of that how do you even [__] think of
that
the when when I was in Afghanistan they
Tau they sent like me and eight other
guys to this like
Advanced like it was like a a medical
course like a course to become like a
baby mini medic right and um this is how
genius these [__] guys are our last
day it's like test day right and it's
like 110 degrees outside but it's 70
degrees were like 80 degrees inside the
AC building we were in right that we're
doing all our last lessons and [__] so
they get the genius [__] idea to keep
the IV bags that we're going to have to
test on each other to make sure we can
give each other IVs
inside inside that inside the AC so it's
time for testing so we go outside and we
have to pretend to be casualties right
so half the class pretends to be
casualties and then you switch right
then the other half treats you and see
if they can handle their
business so we were the second half no
we were the first half I believe second
I can't remember I just remember I
passed the class because they almost
killed us so what they do is they take
these [__] IV bags that are like
almost 40 degrees different from the
ambient temperature outside they keep us
outside for 25 minutes to acclimate and
then they [__] give us these IVs how
many people do you think went in theop
shock every single one of us we didn't
know what was wrong we had no clue what
was wrong except it was Ice going into
or veins and then we could I I can't
[__] breathe man something's hey help
help these are the guyses are treating
we're supposed to be triage and they're
like no stop playing you know like they
thought we were trying to like
exacerbate our role as a [__]
pretending to be somebody that's you
know needs triage no they're [__]
they were almost killed
us I passed that class it was I I have a
certificate in the car I could show
you these stories they get me um they
get me rolling oh here's a funny one so
we're driving and me and my buddy Rick
we're the rear security vehicle right so
we're watching from behind all the whole
Convoy you can see the whole Convoy and
I'm driving I'm like Rick you see that
he's like yeah I [__] saw that and we
saw like eight tracers going into the
Convoy nothing else from the right side
nothing that's all we saw right so we're
calling up and we're we're hey anybody
else get did anybody get shot any
anybody's truck hit any any 18 nope nope
nope no Noe but we only four in those
out of five
trucks right and then the Gunner for
truck number three is the one who
answers not the not the TC the truck
Commander who's supposed to be on the
radio the Gunner does nope nothing
happened
here that's that's a little weird Rick
you smell that he's like yeah smell that
it smells like [__] diesel fuel man
and we're we're escorting half the
trucks were were oil tankers you know we
were fuel
tankers man I smell [__] diesel fuel
dude he's like bro it [__] reeks back
here and I'm like hey we call up and we
go hey is the road wet up
there and the first fourth truck first
first two trucks are like nope nope the
third truck nope the fourth truck is
like yeah it's [__] wet the road's
wet
soaked and me and Rick were like hey man
I is I think somebody [__] truck got
shot up you know one of these one of
these [__] fuel tankers got shot the
[__]
up and uh they're like every hey they're
calling back for bu truck third truck
the Gunner gets nope nope
right so it's time to pull in
taji no this is one of the times we're
going to Anaconda and on the way to
Anaconda when you're north of Baghdad
that base on the road out of it you have
to Swerve like this because there's
[__] potholes from is going off
that'll swallow your truck that would
swallow an 18wheeler dude I'm talking
about it looked like it was bombed and
it's every 10t you're swerving around
these holes right you can't get onto the
base unless you you play The Gauntlet
you know and I'm just like you're just
waiting in between holes for that part
to go up right because you could see
where that had happened all the way down
the [__]
line and we're like man somebody these
[__] one of these goddamn [__]
trucks got shot up and nope nope nope
nope nope and we're like all right fine
right so we pull into the base
anaconda and we
outsourced we of course outsourced
everything there but um the people that
manned the actual Gates and the things
that you have to use to to like the the
barriers that you have to navigate
around and get in on the base was manned
by Ugandan citizens ugandans from
Uganda
so by the time me and Rick on we're
pulling into the base and can imagine
what we're looking at I'm looking at
about 20 fired the [__] up
ugandans dripping in diesel
fuel Furious these men are Furious so
what we didn't know was truck number
three Garza you [__] dick fell asleep
the truck Commander fell asleep and the
Gunner was just you know looking out for
him so the truck in front of them had
got [__] pepper had gotten rattled
you know Chinese that [__] got hit like
nine times so this [__] truck is
spitting diesel fuel out 20 ft out of
these bullet holes and as the [__]
truck pulls in because nobody's saying
anything's wrong the poor [__]
ugandans that are watching they are just
getting doused in diesel fuel finally we
get all the way in and find out what
happened and this dude was like no I
wasn't to sleep it's like how the [__]
didn't you see the goddamn diesel fuel
coming out like a super soer in the 90s
how did you not [__] catch that
bro but that was probably one of the
funniest things I'd ever seen was these
ugandans looking at us with the stare of
death and just diesel
fuel dripping down their [__] face
dude soaking clothes they're yelling
they're throwing their [__] in the air
they're pulling their clothes off and it
was wet it looked like somebody was like
um like you know the water trucks that
keep the dust down it looks like
somebody was going through that [__]
entrance somebody with goddamn diesel
fuel man it were there was um
you know I could sit here and talk about
all the times we shot at human beings I
could tell you all about that you know
when you see a muzzle flash and listen
they call the 50 cal the
Mau and it's the second machine gun the
United States Army ever came out with
and it is the most effective machine gun
we use today it has a 5 and A2 foot
Barrel my brother had a bullet at the
house that I wanted to show you but the
round
where I have a knife that might be able
to give you a small okay if you take a
lighter and you're going to stack it
three
times that's about the size of a 50cal
round and it's it's a it's as round as a
dime a little smaller you know I'm sure
all the [__] Call of Duty kids will
act like they were there and and tell me
all about how I'm wrong but you weren't
Call of Duty
kids because if you've ever been around
a 50 cal when it shoots a 50 cal machine
gun when it shoots you understand that
that's when God talks and that's exactly
how his voice
sounds because when that [__] machine
gun starts barking God's talking and
nobody's
walking I've seen it cut a house in half
like it wasn't [__] their swiss
cheese [__] I've seen it take a car one
round go through a car from one to the
other right out the back a depleted
uranium
like it wasn't there dude do engine
blocks like it wasn't
there and when I said we use large
weapon systems on our vehicles every
single vehicle either had a 50 cal with
a 240 or a 249 next to it or it had a
mark 19 with a 240 or 249 a 240 is a 240
Bravo that's what replaced the M60 a 249
and then that so that shoots a 762 or a
308 whatever you want to call it like
and then a 249 shoots a 5556 same as an
M4 or an
AR-15 um a 5.56 or 223 whatever [__]
whatever I could sit here and tell you
all day about how we'd see a muzzle
flash and somebody would give out a
distance Direction I hear that [__]
50 cal talking and that muzzle flash
goes right the [__] away legally I guess
in the Geneva Convention you're not like
allowed to shoot at people with the 50
cal but you can shoot at their hat you
can shoot at their clothing you can
shoot at their weapon you can shoot at
their canteen
you can shoot their watch you can shoot
their necklace but you cannot shoot
them but if you're wearing clothes you
might get shot with a 50 cal and I you
know people like to talk about this but
it is actually a true principle so you
know the the principle based on if you
stand too close to a train while it's
going by it'll suck you in well the same
thing works for bullets if if the 50
calch fires as it's supersonic right and
it's moving it's so big as it moves by
you it's capable of removing a limb
without touching
you so how [__] fast and hard it
breaks the air around it creates a
vacuum that could tear your [__]
torso half off just passing
by you know you don't I've never heard a
Ricochet of a 50 cal you don't hear
about that nobody if anybody's heard
that I'm guessing they've are dead you
know because it doesn't go if you hear
it it's going to kill you so when that
[__] thing starts going off you can
feel it in your
chest 15t away the machine gun standing
behind it and every truck has one of
these you know so I could sit here and
tell you all day about the destructive
power that we have created in order to
kill each other and I can tell you I've
witnessed it personally I've
participated in it personally I don't
think it's cool to say hey I've taken
life I don't man it's not something that
makes
me it it has created the person that I
am today who I'm super grateful for you
know going through that
experience but to sit and talk about it
bragging to me seems ignorant to me
seems a little [__]
um
misplaced you know if you want to talk
about
war talk about how it affected you as a
person what did it do to the people you
were what about the people on the other
side of that goddamn 50 cal
man I can't
imagine cuz I never had a 50 cal shot of
me I can't
imagine the the fear in somebody's heart
when they heard that sound because that
seriously sounds like God talking man it
sounds like thunder and if it was
pointed at me God I would [__] my bit my
[__] pants but there were men that
stood up bravely and [__] fired their
weapons at
us not knowing they're about to get
chopped the [__] half but that's
exactly how it
went you know we could sit there and I
could tell you there was a guy named
somebody and he did a lot of cool
killing and he really was a badass and
he killed a lot of people cool
like but that's not reality it's not
reality reality doesn't look like that
reality doesn't work like that reality
doesn't have nicknames like
that and if it did I sure as [__]
wouldn't take my truck off-roading to go
do
it I don't know how well you can shoot
at people while your truck's going like
this and if you ever get off of a road
anywhere it's usually how it goes
right I'm sorry I was
just sometimes I'll get personal when I
think something's a little off um you
know the Commander's driver wasn't
usually the man that saw the most action
just to be
honest
um but he did leave the wire I'm sure
you know the commanders do that they do
that
sometimes but they're definitely not the
badasses of the group guys like calling
you the [__] cat out the badasses a
dude they can get blown up and [__]
dust his goddamn fing shoulders off and
just say why me [__] [__] [__] man
[__] [__] why me [__] [__] guys man
that [__] try to kill me all the time
that he was yelling that out loud on the
road man [__] [__] you [__] you you
[__] try to kill me [__]
you my best friend he's my best friend
dud we play pool we shoot darts all the
time in my house I [__] love the guy
he has a God he still doesn't complain
he's the only man that I'll listen to
man because he's like I'll say something
and he's a [__] [__] he'll
wait
and he won't say [__] have you ever
asked somebody a question about like
something serious in life and they
[__] do
that what I didn't realize is whenever
this man opens his [__] mouth Gold's
fall falling out you know because he's
such a humble person that has been
through the guy's got nine goddamn lives
dude he's he's down to seven he's he's
wasted said seven are gone and he's got
two left
and what a [__] beautiful hero that's
a hero in my eyes man
when I think of a soldier I think of
guys like [__] first sergeant
Robinson Captain willan kangy the
[__] cat I don't think of myself you
know I
don't I think of men that I [__] will
admire till the end of time you know
these the image I have of these people
will never change you know people could
get up in the comments say oh I know
that guy he's a
blah I don't care I don't care what the
[__] you think these men are the real
life Heroes out there you know the guys
that they they're they not even citizens
dude they weren't even born afforded the
[__] freedoms and and things we have
but still fought for it because he said
this he explained it to me the other day
he said I didn't want to just become a
citizen I wanted to earn
it are you [__] kidding me I I was
born blessed with [__] the United
States of America and all that it's
given me you know the Constitution and
what it's afforded me just that document
he wanted to [__] he said he wanted
to earn it so he joined our military and
went to war three [__] times and got
shot in an ATM between the first
two and he still doesn't think he
deserves
it and we sit and We complain about the
[__] most mundane
[__] I didn't get this I didn't I
didn't I don't I want I need I I I he's
not even a [__] C he wasn't even a
[__] citizen
man and I've never heard him say he
deserves
anything he never says I got this coming
to me he and he works with vets he works
with Disabled Vets helping them get
their P like their um their disability
rating you
know I don't know how good he is that
he's not really a people person he
doesn't say much he's a man of very few
words but when he talks everybody
listens you know gu that happens when
you get a [__] name calling me the
cat you know but
um all that stuff all these stories all
these things are just that's exactly
what they are they're just stories but
the things that I've I learn more about
I learn more from those experiences
today than I did
then right because I I view the world
differently I view the world is a place
of people that are figuring out how to
love their life and people that are
lost right and the those of us that are
lost are incapable in my
opinion of sifting through their pain
and where the pain has come from and
that's why I think therapy is so good
for people you know especially for like
we're not going to fix this [__] [__]
unless we really get down to what you
talk about the kids and how we raise
them and how to how to avoid
mistreatment and how to talk to them and
how to you know it's not like it was you
know it's not like it it's not the 80s
anymore it's not the 90s anymore it's
not even the early 2000s bush is
gone
it's we have to be okay with other
people not being okay we really do and
by by okay I don't mean oh that's all
right I mean like yo this is real you
know I know like accepting it as okay
not accepting it like o as okay but
accepting it for what it is for exactly
what it is and it's a lot of [__]
human beings in a lot of [__] pain
and if I can bring
any relief to
that that's all I want to do for the
rest of my
life I've created enough pain I've
caused people
pain and that's not who I
am that's not who I am that's not who I
am you know the world you know a lot of
concrete jungles will turn you into a
[__] hard person man and I wasn't
born to be like that you know oh I'm
getting my tattoo removed oh good yeah
Homeboy Industries is doing it like they
they have these people that these cool
ass laser doctors that just volunteer
time like prono and uh uh this kid that
I you you know I I I I attend
um I I don't think I can stay clean by
myself I need help right so I reached
out to a good friend of mine named DJ
that owns a that that runs a place
called noo recovery and his buddy Ryan
and
um uh I can't remember the owner's name
but no her recovery is like a [__]
man they got a recording studio they
have like this huge like $30,000 like
t-shirt making machine and [__] because
they know that when people get clean and
sober they need more than just not
loaded they need to figure out what they
like in life what they love in life and
you know our first
interview it's funny because like I'm
glad that we had that [__] talk mark
because I do know exactly what I want to
do and I'm actually trying to reach that
that's a goal for me is to work in
treatment again in a good healthy legal
place that's not shady and but you know
my my brother actually wants to come on
and talk to you about like body Brokers
have you ever heard of that Fran yep our
friend our mutual friend was a body
broker the one that introduced us now
these are sick [__] man these people
run around and they'll take junkies
and promise them the world just to get
them in treatment so they can get a
quick check money is King yeah man money
is a [__] man money you know
what though money helps things get
comfortable but if I was [__] strung
out and all [__] off when I got the
money that people
donated that money wouldn't do anything
but hurt me that [__] would have [__]
me up it would have been the most
harmful thing yeah it's like everything
needs to be in
moderation right and if you're not in
the right place to have
money you and you know when you're in
the right place to have money because
you keep it you know it goes to what you
need and that's it and when it's gone
you don't have any feelings about it
that's how you know you spent your money
right is when it's gone you have no
feelings left or right you know I'm just
barely barely learning these things in
this age but my son has his the best
version of his father he's ever had and
my God it's amazing When I Wake I wake
up early now and my son now is like he
wants to be out of bed now as soon as
wake up cuz usually I let him sleep for
like another you know cuz I'll get up at
like 600 I don't know about you bro but
like and he he'll want him to crash back
out but no no no he wants to know what
what's up what are we doing is it school
is it time are we going to school what's
up what's up Dad what are we doing and
he just wants to be around me when
usually he was like you know let Dad do
his thing you
know what do you what are you [__]
what do you do man when like what do you
complain about what what
I
man I love the life I have
bro I love the people in this world I
love the people in my life I love the
people I don't [__] know
man I believe that love is the thing
that is the only thing that will fix the
[__] that we see on this
channel how else like how else are we
supposed to do it like if you have pain
and cold in your heart you're [__]
not okay you need help
you need [__] help if you're negative
and you and you literally wake up
thinking about somebody else being in
pain you're wrong you're wrong that's
not that's not living you're not
alive how do we figure it out
again how do we figure it
out look at what just happened like it's
getting worse it's getting worse as I
get better the world around me is
getting worse and it's scaring the [__]
out of me man
because I just sit here told you about
war and how it's not pretty it's not fun
men can get lined up and shot over it
you
know and we're encouraging it as much as
possible oh they did [__] kill
them until somebody lays you on the
[__] ground and hacks you up six
times with a machete like it's happened
to me right in Hawaii
shut your [__] ego up man shut your
[__] ego up I don't want to hear
about how cool it'll be to go to war I
don't want to hear about how they all
need to die because of what they
did I sat on the ground for three and a
half hours and begged a man for my
life begged a man for my
life see that you see
that that's one out of
seven that's me putting my hands out so
saying please don't kill me and he tried
to cut my [__] hand off and he hit me
there I learned some things from that
experience I learned that everything I
thought I was everything I thought
everybody who I thought I was went right
out the window all the [__] that I'd
learned before every fight I'd ever been
in every combat
situation
everything failed me in that moment when
I tripped over a tire and hit my back
and said [__] I was it was so scary when
I tripped and I seen this 4 and 1/2t
machete come up on this dude's arm and I
put myself in that situation I egged it
on I I started the [__] fight not
knowing the dude was holding the goddamn
sword you know but my anger and my ego
placed me in that
position you know I'm not going to
say and let's just say I wasn't the only
person watching I wasn't the only person
person there somebody my my son
watched he had to be there he was there
and he witnessed
it go ahead and and um complain about
all the [__] you got going
on every single morning I wake up clean
or
sober I literally say oh [__] thank God
yes yes I'm up I'm up I made it another
day you
know because with all this chaos with
everything that goes on around us that
we count as
wrong there's so much more things that
are happening that are made from love
and
beauty like God didn't design us to
[__] kill each other man I don't care
what anybody says there's some guy that
like really he like literally started
his own [__] YouTube channel based on
Hutch being dumb about saying war is
unnatural yo guy you ain't never [__]
been then obviously dip
[__] because if you think it's [__]
natural to kill people you should be
separated from the rest of
us
separated in your own [__] Island
where you think it's okay to go kill go
kill over there but leave the rest of us
who want to live in love and [__]
peace and Harmony and [__] figure
this [__] out somehow alone please don't
come near my kid don't go spouting that
[__] reic around rhetoric around my
son don't go talking War there's no such
thing as humanitarian
Aid that ends in weapons F sending a
missile to somebody to kill people with
isn't humanitarian [__] Aid where
have we lost our way man where have we
lost our way when we say hey we got this
much money and humanitarian Aid
humanitarian Aid is now being used by
people we have
elected we have elected these people who
say humanitarian Aid is bombs and
bullets H
H maybe I've lost my way by thinking
this way I don't know maybe I'm the one
that's all twisted up and [__] stupid
by thinking yeah we got to
help those people go to war [__] you
guys man [__] you [__] people that
are so ignorant you don't know you don't
know what war is you don't you don't
understand it
it's a man blown the [__] half
begging for his [__] mom the things
that were coming out of that kid's
mouth nothing about it spoke
humanitarian Aid to me you know what it
did it made me put my fingers in my ear
turn around and walk away cuz I could
not listen to that man beg for his life
anymore on the ground and I couldn't do
anything for him I remember there was so
much blood there's so much blood in the
[__] human body man there was a Red
Bull can that when he [__] came out
of his truck in half there was a Red
Bull can on the ground and it was
[__] it was like this man that much
of it was
blood like it was floating in his
[__] blood and for all you
humanitarian Aid people when somebody
gets hurt like that that it starts to
turn pink it co the blood's still trying
to coagulate you know so it gets this
like white foam this like white pink
foam on top of it you
know it's not like the movies where it
just pours out
evenly there's nothing beautiful about
it there's nothing pretty about it I
find no I cannot think about it in any
way other than [__] Carnage man I
don't hear humanitarian Aid in his
screams for his mom and his screams for
his kids and his screams for his life
you know when I was down there begging
this dude for my [__] life please
don't [__] kill me dog I'm sorry bro
please don't kill my
kid and he said I remember my son was
screaming like please please don't kill
my daddy and he goes shut that mud up or
I'll kill him too and my son went sign
silent for 3 hours he was sitting in my
truck watching me get hit with this
machete over and over and over and the
guy had a friend with him standing over
my shoulder so for all the ones that are
like oh I would have I would I would
have trust me you wouldn't have sorry
there was no getting out of it and
here's the crazy
part as the cops drove by I told them
hey hide your machete I'm going to sit
up so they don't know what's going
on because I didn't want them to take my
kid
I knew this guy wasn't I didn't think he
was going to kill me because I didn't
try to kill him at all I I barely he
didn't bleed to drop but what I did was
over the top and I was [__] talking
[__] to him that's the best part I'm
talking cash [__] to this dude he's a
[__] he's a punk he's a blah blah blah
that goddamn sword came up and guess who
was the [__] the punk blah blah blah
this [__] guy man this guy and then
my [__] brain went to my
kid I'm there's a machete between me and
my son and I'm on the
ground and a dude talking about he's
going to kill
us I could have used some humanitarian
Aid right right I mean [__] should I
could have used a goddamn cluster
bomb that's the other thing how how are
how is it how is it that cluster bombs
are inh humanitary like they're not
Humane when the Russians are using them
but it is when we are stockpiled with
them and send them to Ukraine because we
want to give them our old [__] and
humanitarian Aid of course bags of rice
and
bullets where are we man to where when
Israel gets
attacked the world wants to go to
war do we're still seeing this as a
solution
huh we're still seeing this as a
solution killing other people is a
solution where are the sound Minds where
are the level heads where are the people
talking about this like for the reality
it is where are the Vets I want where
are my Bros at saying yo yo yo y don't
y'all don't want any part of this [__]
you guys don't want any [__] part of
this you think it's cute because you
play video games I've had dudes trying
to school me on [__] that I've done
based off of [__] Call of Duty oh
yeah it was like when you were like this
did you have this weapon and I'm like
bro
I say their thumbs working you know and
they really think they're there because
they've see they play this game so
much the ironic thing is this right
before we were leaving Iraq they came
out with this weapon system called a
crow system crew remote operated weapon
okay or or something cab it was
literally a the Gunner sat behind the
driver and he had a screen and you know
what kind of controller he had in his
hand an Xbox
controller and he could zoom a 50 cal
God's breath he could zoom it in up to a
mile and it had thermal imaging it had
um night vision Capac capabilities and
there was no Gunner sitting out of the
roof it was and it it could do 360
degrees and 6
seconds Xbox remote why do you think
they did that I do you think they use
Xbox
remount there's a good reason for it I
promise because you know it's easy to
turn that into somebody's reality it's
easy to go from the video game to the
it's just a screen you know it's not
people on the other side of that no man
everybody was made by two people all of
us that live here had two people that
put us here even if both your parents
are dead there's
there's somebody's going to [__] miss
you you know so every life that's
taken somebody is is devastated by that
I gu it's like it's I mean of course
there's those [__] loners and stuff
but every single life that is
taken devastates
somebody that devastate somebody that
was not the person that was intended to
be devastated you
know so for those people that are like
eager to get out there and and be a part
of a war eager to get out there and and
and run it back or [__] slide or do
whatever it is that that you're trying
to
do you're going to have to live with it
man
and to live with it is to have to hear
the voices of those people that are
devastated in your mind without ever
meeting them because if you don't hear
those voices you need to be separated
from the rest of us you do because then
you're not
learning from something that everybody
should know is wrong
you're not learning and I've learned and
if there's something I've learned is
that
peace is worth
it peace is worth it it's worth it Mark
I
promise I think it's all I got dude
awesome H you're amazing I love you dud
I do I
do